buonasera insegno matematica da più di
30 anni sono laureata in matematica e ai
voi forse adoro la matematica per me la
matematica è stata un'amica ed è
un'amica una consigliera una maestra di
vita mi ha permesso e mi ha permesso il
riscatto sociale cioè mi ha permesso di
diventare quello che sono oggi mi ha
portato a trovare la radice della mia
vita e per dirla in termini matematici
la radice quadrata della mia vita mi
guardate con le facce così perché come
può la matematica far questo è quello
che cercherò di spiegarvi nel mio tempo
oggi parto da qui guardate questa foto
se vi chiedessi chi sono queste due
persone probabilmente mi deve essere una
coppia la coppia lui penso tutti
possiate dirmi che einstein e lui ansa e
lei chi è
e lui è famoso perché cosa per la teoria
della relatività ristretta e generale
me lo direste tutti premio nobel della
fisica per l'aver scoperto e spiegato
l'effetto fotoelettrico e lei chi è
bene lei mileva maric e chi è lei base è
con einstein sarà la moglie di einstein
è la moglie di einstein peccato che
nessuno sappia che einstein non avrebbe
potuto scrivere e scoprire la teoria
della relatività se non avesse avuto sua
moglie che è una matematica è stata una
matematica una fisica importantissima
che gli faceva tutti i calcoli perché
lui non era capace di farlo infatti lui
diceva questo ho bisogno nel 1903 disse
pubblicamente questo ho bisogno di mia
moglie lei risolve tutti i miei problemi
matematici
lo diceva eppure noi oggi non sappiamo
chi sia ancora quella donna ma vengo a
tempi più recenti
se vi faccio vedere questa donna
voi mi dite che è nessuno
la riconosce lei è una donna matematica
purtroppo devo dire era perché è morta a
soli 40 anni madre moglie madre moglie
una donna iraniana ed è stata la prima
donna a vincere la medaglia fields nel
la medaglia fields è una sorta di nobel
della matematica perché come voi sapete
il nome della matematica non esiste
l'equivalente questo quindi noi abbiamo
dovuto aspettare fino al 2014 per avere
il nobel della matematica dato a una
donna
e allora mi viene da dire perché perché
non conosciamo mileva maric che ha fatto
quello che fa
perché vi ho detto prima è perché
abbiamo dovuto aspettare fino al 2014
per avere un premio nobel della
matematica
perché succede questo
quando io ti amo tantissimo una domanda
che è questa quando conosco qualcuno che
lavoro fai e lo dico in segno fino a lì
tutto va bene poi mi chiedono che cosa
insegna matematica
oddio si fanno questa faccia però alla
matematica no non dormivo soprattutto
non a caso le donne anche prima mi è
successo mi tiravo mi tingo i capelli
nodi fanno moltissime di queste hanno
moltissime di queste espressioni ma
allora perché si pensa che la matematica
sia solo per pochi e dico per pochi
perché anche per poche quasi nessuno
perché si pensa che è la matematica
prima di tutto sia un insieme di formule
e basta che sostanzialmente non servono
a niente se non a tormentare i sonni
notturni specialmente delle ragazze è in
realtà per la matematica ci sia bisogno
di un quid quel quid che o ce l'hai o se
non fai quella faccia precedente e
guarda caso liquida se ce l'hanno
per la maggior parte sono uomini e
allora dico ancora ma la matematica non
è quella la matematica non è far di
conto
la matematica è questo è stupefacente è
un'avventura dell'immaginazione
pensate le geometrie non euclidee per
spiegare la teoria dell'attività di
heinz e immaginarsi 1
piano che non sia più quello che abbiamo
noi in mente ma che sia una superficie
la sfera immaginate quello è la musica
della ragione è un'arte un atto poetico
e visionario e libertà e libertà perché
ci fa capire quali sono le cose
fondamentali della vita ci fa a
decodificare questo mondo ma rispetto
alle informazioni
quando noi scegliamo possiamo utilizzare
il ragionamento matematico per non farci
ingannare una volta una mia studentessa
alla fine della quinta mi scrisse questo
grazie professoressa per avermi fatto
capire che la matematica non è solo un
insieme di formule ma è un modo di
affrontare la vita semplificandola col
ragionamento e la fantasia ecco che
cominciate a capire che cosa significa
quando io ho detto per me la matematica
è un'amica una maestra di vita
e ancora a chi dice che la matematica al
massimo non serve a niente
io non la userò mai
guardiamo un problema pratico questa
l'ha fatto una mia studentessa avevo
spiegato alle rette e gli avevo detto
avevo detto ai miei studenti adesso è
studente ai se trovate degli esempi
pratici di tutti i giorni
bene lei è arrivata con questo esempio
devo andare in palestra
non so che abbonamento prendere capita a
tutti noi cosa prendo un abbonamento
dove c'è un tasso fisso al mese paga una
cifra fissa parco una cifra variabile
che dipende bene in due secondi di
segnando tre reti io so che se sono
pigro prenderò una palestra
se sono vado normalmente un'alta e se
sono super questo 5 secondi
disegnare le reti ci si mette un attimo
la soluzione io sceglierò quella giusta
e quindi risparmiando dei soldi forse
per la palestra a meno ma pensate se
dovesse investire qualcosa di più
importante magari i risparmi di una vita
e allora ancora perché la matematica è
percepita così ebbe perché qualcuno mi
diceva bene
lorella tu mi hai detto tutte queste
cose e adesso mi devi spiegare che cosa
succede perché però le se la matematiche
tutto questo io nelle prove di
matematica dell'ocse o 20 punti in meno
dei maschi delle femmine rispetto ai
maschi e cieli o sui livelli alti
ma perchè queste sono tutte perché
esistono gli stereotipi
questo è il problema
esistono gli stereotipi che ci fanno
percepire come la matematica come
qualcosa che di una competenza di un
quid innato di un'abilità che noi
abbiamo innata e guarda caso se di
qualcuno e dei maschi ma come può essere
no questa cosa a volte dico agli amici
vabbè ma noi che cosa siamo siamo nati
geneticamente modificate con il genere
della matematica e meno non è possibile
allora da dove nasce questo stereotipo
ce lo spiega carlo ii carlo ii che è una
psicologa dello sviluppo e sociale
dell'università di stanford
lei è andata analizzare la differenza di
rendimento tra i maschi e le femmine che
cosa ci dice card due che sono gli
stereotipi e in particolare in famiglia
e a scuola ci sono dei condizionamenti
incredibili che fa sì che limitano la
performance ma non solo nell'immediato
ma anche nel futuro cioè le ragazze non
si sentono capaci di poter fare facoltà
matematiche è di poter avere una
carriera è dimostrato scientificamente
lei ha fatto una sperimentazione
scientifica quindi e dove nascono come
vi ho detto prima questi stereotipi in
famiglia principalmente oltre che a
scuola perché questa alle bambine
diciamo di essere obbedienti di perfett
ai maschi invece diciamo di osare di
essere coraggiosi pensate quando arriva
una bambina e va dal papa gli dici papa
non so fare i compiti di matematica il
90 per cento il papa gli dice bene non
ti preoccupare se non ce la fai
probabilmente avrai una vena artistica o
una vena balistica farai quello nella
vita viene il maschietto e gli dice e no
allenati provaci vedrai che ce la farai
allora se è vero questo possiamo dire
che il gioco o meglio il danno è già
fatto ma allora lite va bene lorella ci
ha detto tutto negativo
adesso dc come facciamo a cambiare le
cose bene prima di tutto pensando noi
stessi e interiorizzando che la
matematica è per tutti
oltre che per tutti è per tutte ed è
solo questione di allenamento di
allenamento che cosa di allenare il
pensiero perché se la matematica è un
quell'atto visionario noi dobbiamo
allenare il pensiero
perché qui perché noi dobbiamo contare
dobbiamo contare per puntare
e allora come facciamo ad allenare il
pensiero possiamo allenare il pensiero
facendo un allenamento preciso su che
cosa sulla un allenamento preciso sul
sull'attività di immaginazione
progettazione pensato il pensiero
matematico il pensiero matematico che
cosa significa e dovete ipotizzare
progettare intuire e come fate fate
proprio allenando in questo pensiero che
ce lo dice ce lo dice fi e hspa i fires
time è uno psico pedagogista nato in
romania figlio di ebrei si è occupato
delle carenze cognitive dei bambini che
erano sopravvissuti alle regie razziali
li ha portati al livello degli altri
quindi l'idea e noi in qualunque età in
qualunque momento la nostra mente è
modificabile con degli esercizi
opportuni bene se mettiamo assieme sia
caro il 2 che fai e stein possiamo
vincerli questi stereotipi
cosa faccio io e le mie studentesse dico
prima di tutto che possono usare gli do
delle sfide queste sfide alte loro col
mio aiuto le risolvono non solo si
allenano e immaginate di dover sollevare
dei pesi che cosa cominciate cominciate
a sollevare i pesi da kg 2 chili e
andate avanti
a questo punto che cosa succederà che
poi riuscirete anche a sollevare pesi
alti ma se voi continuate a dire io non
ce la farò
non ce la farete mai se allenate le
braccia e non le gambe non ce la farete
quindi l'idea è allenare la mente un
esempio pratico alle mie studentesse e
anche i miei studenti faccio scrivere ad
esempio dei testi teatrali su argomenti
matematici pensate l'anno scorso la mia
è una mia classe di seconda ha scritto
un testo teatrale sulle geometrie non
euclidee testo teatrale che ha
rappresentato
pensate cosa è riuscita a fare e quanta
forza ma non ha avuto e non ha
sviluppato la capacità di immaginare
progettare dedurre ha sviluppato proprio
questo
ecco io sono mi vedo come un'allenatrice
che allena gli studenti e le studentesse
a raggiungere la maratona perché se la
maratona se la matematica diventa parte
di noi noi riusciamo ad arrivare dove
vogliamo nessuno ci condizionerà più
neanche gli stereotipi potranno avere
successo
allora che cosa dobbiamo pensare che la
matematica e questo in matematica è
libertà quindi se la matematica diventa
parte di noi possiamo trovare la nostra
vera radice perché ho detto alla radice
quadrata della vita perché la radice
quadrata come voi sapete esiste per
valori della quantità sotto radice
maggiore o uguale a zero quindi se la
matematica diventa un modo di affrontare
la vita
superiamo ogni stereotipo
nessuno ci potrà ingannare noi capiremo
chi siamo e la nostra vita diventerà
positiva esattamente come quella di
caldo quindi possiamo dire che la
matematica è libertà e quindi auguro a
tutti voi di trovare la vostra
radice quadrata della vita e quindi buon
allenamento matematico
grazie
[Applauso]